dann lassen sie uns doch ein
weihnachtslied singen ok welche schlagen
sie vor
also ich kann nur last christmas sie
trinken das bier und dann können sie
jedes lied
sagt man eigentlich hier ist dietmar
bartsch von der linken oder dietmar
bartsch von die linke oder dietmar
bartsch von der die linke also ich würde
sagen
dietmar bartsch von der linken wenn man
es glaube ich ganz korrekt macht es ist
von der die linke aber man sagt schon
immer dietmar und nidda dpa
ich bin ja sehr froh dass die frau
wagenknecht heute nicht da ist weil ich
glaube dieses intelligente sich wir
müssen in zuckerguss herstellen aus
eiweiß und puderzucker
okay ganz schön cool noch wie ich das
getrennt habe ja so aber da ist noch so
groß rausgekommen dass ich trotz hallo
sagen wir es ist ein bisschen schneller
das ganze muss da rein also alles da
das ist ja gemeint das ist ja gemeint
dass das schwierig würde ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt
sie war christian lindner party gast
also die zu hause das muss ungefähr
diese konsistenz haben wenn ihr eine
kalorienärmere version machen wollt ihr
könnt auch anstatt pfefferkuchen einfach
pfefferspray benutzen
dann wird halt so ein bisschen
abstrakter architektonisch aber dafür
einbruch sichern
mir ist aufgefallen dass sehr viele
interviews so gerade von der heute show
die sind so ein bisschen unfair und ich
wollte eigentlich gerade bei so einer
netten partei wie der linken nicht dass
sie dann so unfair behandelt werden
deswegen habe ich ihnen ein paar
schlagfertigkeit karten mitgebracht mit
sachen die sie dann auch sagen können
wenn sie keine idee haben aber das sind
eigentlich einfach beleidigungen die
gehen nur sagen kann ja genau
hänsel und gretel more like hazel
antreten das ist aber nicht so fein ich
will noch nicht geregelt sein
wir meinen nein warum nicht frauen sind
doch willst du weniger gut aus wenn er
sonst würden sie doch nicht weniger
verdienen ich habe ja die theorie dass
frauen weniger verdienen weil mütter 21
prozent mehr geliebt werden von ihren
kindern
ich glaube das ist unsinn ist und ich
finde das auch alles richtig schwachsinn
egal wie viel ich glaube sie haben das
gleiche verdient zu bekommen nur nicht
das gleiche und das für dieses problem
aber wieso gehen die frauen dann nicht
einfach auf die straße
zünden autos an finde ich eine variante
die sinnvoll sein kann
ich finde es gibt in märchen sehr
schlechtes frauen
das stimmt das stimmt das stimmt wobei
in dem fall muss man ja mal sagen bei
hänsel und gretel ist einer der wenigen
stories wo die helden das mittel ist
hensel ist ja da drin und musste sich
stiefmutter aber hallo gretel rettet
alles ist so dämlich und lässt die
routinen raus wir hatten das ding
entschieden als das vertreten
36 reichsten in deutschland besitzen
soviel wie die hälfte der bevölkerung in
deutschland
solange das so ist ist was schräg das
ist dann trotzdem nur 92 die linke
wählen ist ja noch was schräger oder
also z da stand dann das stimmt er da es
ist ja deswegen mache ich auch weiter
es ist natürlich ist das immer relativ
aber sie wirken eigentlich viel zu
sympathisch um politiker zu sein
noch so ein satz soll ich jetzt auch mal
so eine kleine bosheit sagen ja sie
können ja gerne eine von ihren
schlagfertigkeit karten raus genauer
homburger sie würden doch ziemlich
intelligent
warum arbeiten sie trotzdem mal im
fernsehen sie haben mir die karte
gegeben ich kann nichts dafür
meine idee so von meiner hexe hat ein
kopftuch finde ich jetzt ein bisschen zu
beladen für weihnachten werden die leute
ja extrem empfindlich versuche es mal
sagte zu entfernen
sie wechselt muss ja dann eine blutende
wange das ist sagen die man geht nicht
so mit messern an frauen und was man
eigentlich auch nicht wie alt sind sie
ja dass man sieht's nicht mehr ganz
schön schon in den 50ern wenn es mir
gedacht hahaha ich hätte gedacht sie
sind ein 14-jähriger raucher jetzt
wieder die karten aber so beleidigt frau
bürger sind für die deutschen
unterhaltungsindustrie das kopernikus
die germanistik war irrelevant warten
kracher ich finde die karten dann müssen
wir ihre reaktion sagen wie kann man
auch besser vorbereiten also schon um
diese sucht man die karten das hätte ich
nie gedacht was ist ihr lieblings
weihnachtslied und jetzt nicht bitte
nicht so ein ddr quatsch so was ist ein
ddr quatsch bitte damit weiß und
quatschen der ddr wurden dieselben
weihnachtslieder gesungen die
schon immer in deutschland üblich war
bald nun ist weihnachtszeit fröhliche 2
nun ist der weihnachtsmann gar nicht
mehr
mehr wahr gemacht sind sie zufrieden
jänner schon immobilienmakler der hat
hier zwei im angebot wer hat das schon
also ich glaube wenn ein bescheideneres
und 1 also halt schweiz mit den
millionen und vorpommern wo es etwas
weniger futter gibt aber ich glaube wenn
jeder in einem lebkuchenhaus wohnen
würde dann wäre sehr sehr viele in
deutschland bald obdachlos obdachlos und
sehr übergewichtig dass ihre das
mindestens genauso große problem endlich
in wir anbieten können sie das klar
na ja auch die opposition